voici à quoi ressemble aujourd'hui le
projet et voici ce que dans quelques
lignes les amateurs de pompe à tours on
faire car pour arriver au niveau du
champion du monde il faudra de
l'entraînement pour leurs chaînes et
gainey a troqué son vélo contre les
vêtements de travail
ça fait un petit moment que j'en fais
même personnellement depuis que je suis
jeune j'ai toujours fait plus
officiellement avec ma société depuis
septembre 2018 donc c'est notre sixième
réalisation est sûrement la plus grande
vendredi dernier on a vraiment fini le
gros-oeuvre yann était compacte et et
avait des jeunes qui attendaient depuis
déjà toute la semaine on l'a dit bon
allez les gars vous pouvez y aller ils
ont fait quelques tours et je pense
qu'ils ont hâte d'essayer une fois finie
et plus le temps passe plus les pistes
prennent forme plus l'impatience des
jeunes grandit on fait on fait beaucoup
de vélo dans dans la ville mais ya pas
ou il n'y a pas d'installation du tout
et oui on a participé à la demande on a
participé à la mise en place aussi on
est des cons un petit peu
[Musique]
à modeler un peu le terrain j'ai tout
essayé mais le mieux c'est le virage
parce qu'on peut prendre de la vitesse
après là on peut sauter aussi du coup
c'est vrai que c'est pas mal
des jeunes qui compte aussi sur la
réputation de cette installation pour
les sortir de leur isolement car il n'en
doute pas les pistes seront très vite
très connu d'autres jeunes qui viendront
l'essayer